This hypotenuse here would be 40 units in length. Great job if you've found
this number. Remember, these are the legs of the triangle, since they form the
90 degree angle. The side across from the 90 degree angle, this side is called
the hypoteneuse. We don't know the length of the hypoteneuse, so we'll call it
x. We'll start with our Pathagorean Theorem and we'll plug in the numbers for
the legs here and then hypotenuse here. So, we'll have 32 squared plus 24
squared equals x squared. We'll square each of these numbers and then we'll
have these two added together equals x squared. This gives us 1600 equals x
squared. Now we want to take the square root of both sides of the equation to
solve for x. When we take the square root, we'll need to include the plus or
minus symbol. But, in this case, since the distance is positive, we can
disregard the negative root. We only want the positive root. This gives us x
equals 40, or 40 units in length. Now, there's another way to solve this
problem. And it involves a 3, 4, 5 right triangle. This is one of our special
triangles. For our special right triangle, the side links are the ratio of 3 to
4 to 5. It turns out the side lengths of this triangle are in the same exact
ratio. We know that the legs are 24 and 32. So, I'm going to put those here. If
we multiply this leg by eight, we would end up with 24. And if we multiply this
leg by eight, we would wind up with 32. So, we can see that eight would be the
multiplier for this ratio. So, to get the side length of a hypotenuse of this
triangle we would just need to multiple 5 by 8. This is another way without
using the Pythagorean Theorem that we can find this hypotenuse.